los eventos deportivos de alto perfil
como el mundial de Qatar reflejan lo que
está ocurriendo también en toda la
geopolítica internacional pareciera que
el interés de Qatar ahora están
incrementar su propio poder y también
influencia occidente tendrá que asumir
que el emirato seguirá siendo por varios
años uno de los actores internacionales
más influyentes en esa región saludamos
a Luis Carlos Olivares él es economista
y abogado especialista en análisis de
políticas o públicas para el desarrollo
profesor universitario y asesor
parlamentario Luis Carlos Gracias por
estar con nosotros esta mañana de
viernes en directo América de France 24
un gusto y vamos a hablar de el fútbol y
la energía que no parecen estar muy de
la mano por esta vez sí porque
Qatar es un ganador con el mundial es
también y con la guerra en Ucrania por
qué lo podemos decir de esta manera
muy buenos días es un gusto estar en su
espacio Pues bien
Qatar podría considerarse o hay quienes
podrían considerarlo como un motor
Regional de crecimiento sobre todo
debido a su plan de expansión en los
próximos años sin embargo eso es una
afirmación de plausividad contrastable
Qatar ya ha sido un lustro más o menos
ha venido emprendiendo un plan expansivo
en términos económicos Pero también es
cierto que esa empresa expansiva ha
tenido algunos retrocesos relacionados
principalmente con su capacidad
instalada una de las señas más claras
acerca de este plan se refleja
justamente en que una de las compañías
petroleras más grandes del mundo como es
Qatar petróleo de agosto del año
anterior había elegido a la
multinacional española la técnica
reunidas de hasta Julio 2019 había
formado parte 35 para participar de la
ejecución de un Macro proyecto de
expansión del campo de gas Norte
todo esto manteniendo un contrato de PC
o de ingeniería compras que puesta en
marcha con una adjudicación que ascendía
a los 500 millones de dólares con otras
empresas había tenido algunos algunos
contratos en sumas ascendían hasta los
hasta los 1.200 millones de dólares
tan es así que Qatar petróleo colocó el
año pasado una serie de bonos por un
mundo de mil quinientos millones de
dólares lo que demuestra su intención de
financiar a través del resto del mundo
la expansión de la capacidad instalada
para la licuefacción de gas con ese
desarrollo de este pasaría de tener la
capacidad de 77 a 110 millones de
toneladas anuales en términos de
producción de gastos entonces podemos
decir que se trata de una apuesta
estratégica
Luis Carlos occidente se va a tener que
acostumbrar acatar a por muchos años más
Digamos como un influyente país dentro
de la región de medio oriente
evidentemente por la energía como Lo
acabamos de hablar
Claro que sí vamos a ver ya inicios de
este 2022 el presidente biden había
dicho que nombraría acatar Aliado mayor
no miembro de la otan sí
Washington concede solo a socios muy
especiales y esta intentona por
reivindicar la posición de la
geopolítica mundial de Qatar respondida
por un lado a lo que a los efectos que
había tenido lo que ya había sucedido
con el diplomático
algarabía a propósito de los juegos de
bikini pero no deja de hacer una
declaración de intenciones por parte de
occidente es decir No cabe duda que en
términos económicos cantar representa un
mercado muy apetecible pero lo que ha
primado en cuanto a las relaciones
qatarías por el resto del mundo es el
pragmatismo
de gas hacia tanto como la tímida
impugnación que hiciera en su momento
acerca de las actuaciones rusas aún
cuando por otro lado mencionar a que
estaban a favor de la presentación de la
soberanía ucraniana y demás creo que la
apuesta cataría más bien como el Aliado
que Todos quieren como un buen sustituto
emergente como una especie de contrapeso
de Mercado u oferta perfecta alternativa
que restaría presión a la demanda sobre
el gas en términos generales a nivel
internacional Luis Carlos también
podemos decir que atrás quedaron estos
señalamientos de Qatar a como un
supuesto patrocinador del terrorismo
también en todo lo que tiene que ver con
los derechos humanos en ese país porque
evidentemente pues los intereses
económicos opriman en muchas ocasiones
sobre eso digamos para hacer una
comparación con nuestra región también
lo podemos ver de alguna manera con
Estados Unidos y Venezuela que a raíz de
toda esta guerra en Ucrania que pues
evidentemente es un gran detonante para
todas las cosas que estamos viendo y
todas las consecuencias que estamos
viendo el día de hoy en la geopolítica
internacional Pues el gobierno de Joe
biden se acercó también al gobierno de
maduro entonces la economía prima sobre
las otras cosas
justamente Yo pienso que el pragmatismo
en las relaciones internacionales sobre
todo la coyuntura en donde la necesidad
está en el orden del día nos lleva a
poder afirmar algo que puede ser posible
que en economía tanto como en política
no hay sillas vacías verdad Entonces
desde esa perspectiva uno podría pensar
que las relaciones que o los alegatos
que se hacían contra algunos de estos
países que usted bien menciona pues
pasan a un segundo plano en virtud de la
necesidad de que estos países tienen
para suplir la demanda de gas que tiene
occidente entonces Desde esa perspectiva
la dependencia
del gas está dando siempre presente por
mucho tiempo y con el advenimiento de
conflicto occidente entonces debió
buscar alternativas para suplir su
dependencia derivados del petróleo tan
es así que por ejemplo Julio ya después
de finanzas alemanas para que los
productores de petróleo no redujeran la
oferta y manipular a los precios y eso
demuestra la gran necesidad gran
dependencia que siguen teniendo algunos
de estos países Y lo demuestra también
la búsqueda constante de alternativas
entre ellas